the community coming together to support  our fallen heroes a car wash fundraiser  event was held earlier today  in the south part of the valley  organizations joined efforts to raise  money to benefit the injured police  officers fund  in honor of nhp trooper mike may and  metro police officer jason swanger  trooper may died last week after he was  hit by a carjacking suspect on july 27th  officer swanger passed away on june 24  from covid 19 complications  when we have a tragedy it's the  community that comes  as a whole and it's  it's so nice for the families the  survivors  that they see that that people are just  really genuinely they're invested in our  las vegas  families and that's what they do  the ipof raises money to help reduce the  financial burden  suffered by police officers and their  families in the event of a line of duty  injury or death  if you want to make a donation we have a  link on our website 8newsnow.com